hello everyone welcome to another
episode of about q a about future of
Science and Technology this is uh part I
now have four Series going and on
Fridays I'm alternating between future
science and technology and my
long-running uh
q a about science and technology for
kids and others
so today talking about future of science
and technology so I see there are a
bunch of questions saved up here my gosh
lots and lots of them
uh
DIY asks do you think the latest
electric car is worth buying for these
days what is the future of cars I'm not
a close follower of all of the different
offerings of cars so I'm not sure I can
comment on that but the general question
of what the future of cars is is sort of
interesting
um I think there are a bunch of things
to say about that
um I mean it's worth
so first point is uh there are uh
cars have been around for a bit more
than 100 years huge infrastructure built
out of paved roads and all these kinds
of things for cars and uh uh the and
also the effect of cars on kind of the
geography of the world and the fact that
suburbs could exist and things like this
have been has been quite dramatic and
people have been saying for years oh
there'll be some situation in which
there are start to be these excerpts and
you know people living in nice Mountain
spots and so on that are quite hard to
access by by car but there'll be some
other way to access them I think the
main thing that will be interesting to
see is when do some kind of uh you know
personal flying vehicles really come
into existence I mean flying cars have
been predicted they've been a feature of
the future for at least 100 years you
know you look at issues of you know
Popular Mechanics or whatever from close
to 100 years ago and you'll see pictures
of you know the future is flying cars
type thing blind cars why haven't they
happened you know there was a time
I remember well 50 years ago or
something now in a helicopters were the
were the thing where everybody's going
to have a helicopter
and there were occasionally for example
around you know where I live in the in
the Boston area uh a company digital
Equipment Corporation which for a while
was the second largest computer company
after IBM had the idea that they would
have their sort of facilities dotted
around New England and all the execs
would go from place to place by
helicopter
it's the only company I know that tried
to do it that way helicopters didn't
work out to be nearly as easy to deal
with as people expected they require a
lot of Maintenance they're hard to fly
the whole thing is sort of an expensive
thing to operate
and so now the question is will there be
a moment where kind of the the flying
car-ish thing really comes into
existence I think the answer is
definitely yes there's nothing sort of
against the laws of physics
to uh about having a flying car the
issue has to do with sort of the
trade-offs between battery density and
energy density in batteries and uh how
how heavy the car needs to be you know
I've seen demos oh gosh several I mean I
saw one at the Consumer Electronics Show
maybe six seven years ago they had a uh
a thing that um well admittedly it was
stationary on the show show floor but it
was a a claimed sort of personal uh
drone type thing I saw another one again
it was stationary on um I've seen
several stationary on uh on lawns and
things but I don't I've never seen one
actually uh uh flying with a person in
it so to speak I mean the issue is if
you want to have a small surveillance
drone cargo delivery drone it can be
there's you can just deal with you know
packages under five pounds but we humans
don't come in packages under five pounds
um and so the sort of a minimum size
necessary to be a useful thing to
transport humans around you know I'm
remembering now a a company I saw
present with business plans for kind of
personal drone Transportation oh maybe
two years ago now so this is something
sort of bubbling up
um and uh when will it really happen
well so
one is Battery Technology energy density
of batteries the other is can you
actually have a a drone
type thing that is easy enough to fly
that either somebody can control it
themselves or it can be uh you know this
sounds a bit scary you know centrally
controlled and you're just a passenger
and you're sort of in the Drone
um and I suppose the other possibility
is piloted kind of self-driving cars
with actual sort of qualified uh kind of
Uber driver style but they're Uber pilot
style folks instead my guess is that's
not economically viable for all sorts of
reasons
um but uh
um
so you know a question will be let's
imagine that eventually kind of uh uh
the um
sort of drone like individual
um
uh flying vehicles become practical in a
way that helicopters have not been
um the uh and presumably it will be the
electric version of these things that
becomes practical although that's not
self-evidently uh how it has to be but
my guess is that that's that's how it
will actually play out and in fact I
think it's much easier to have I mean
when one sees drones they tend to be uh
you know a lot of the rotor based ones
that they're they are electrical and I I
suspect it's easier to have an electric
motor respond quickly than it is to have
some other uh kind of um combustion
motor respond quickly and that probably
makes it easier to do flight control for
such things but any case the uh the
question would be let's say that sort of
it was possible to have flying cars
basically what effect would that have
well no doubt it will change real estate
values no doubt it will change you know
commute times change dramatically people
are not stuck in traffic jams there's a
lot more room in three dimensions than
there is in in the one dimension of a
road so to speak uh I think that um
um
it but you know it's unclear to me the
fact that it's going to be interesting
question how long it takes once there
really are viable kind of um drone
flying cars so to speak how long it will
be before those things become common
um and whether that's a five-year story
a 10-year story a 20-year story I'm not
sure and then how long it will be before
that has significant effects on the way
people kind of lay out real estate and
so on I mean there are a tiny number of
places in the world where there's sort
of a a local uh light aircraft you know
private plane airport and people
literally um you know know they land on
the runway and then they kind of Taxi
their plane to their kind of garage and
their house and the houses all sort of
arranged around the runway they're a
very small number I've never seen one in
person but I've seen pictures of them
um of of places that are set up that way
but that would presumably become much
more the norm you know I think the thing
that's supposed to be coming soon is you
know Amazon is trying another effort to
make uh
um drone delivery work and kind of the
way that that's planned is you kind of
pick on a map
um where you want the Drone to to land
and it will it's rather noisy I think
right now but it will it will come and
land there and drop off your five pound
package or whatever
um I think one might have thought that
there would be uh would be better to
have sort of you know set up The Landing
Pad in your backyard but I think that
it's it's believed it's better to just
have people sort of select the place on
a um on a map that so you don't have to
mess around worrying about whether uh
you know whether the local Wildlife had
chewed up your landing pad and so that's
why you didn't get your latest delivery
so to speak there
let's see
uh
question from zengeth with technology
integration we'll be able to do away
with having to sleep in the future
you know sleep is one of those sort of
scientific mysteries of of exactly why
is sleep necessary
I personally have long assumed that the
real answer is when brains operate they
produce a certain amount of waste
product just by virtue of the process of
thinking so to speak and that one needs
to clean that out much as you know if
you exercise a muscle you produce lactic
acid and you have to wait for that to
kind of clear itself out before you can
go on using that muscle without it being
tired and I think oh gosh what is it
there's a um
oh my I think it's actually an amino
acid that that gets produced as a result
of repeated uh neural firings and sort
of one of the common theories of sleep
is that you need to clean that out and
that it's hard to clean out while the
brain is in operation so to speak
you know as is so common in biology once
you have a phenomenon like sleep
biology piles on lots of functions for
that for that phenomenon and sleep
exists down certainly to fishes
um and uh possibly even lower animals
than that uh that there are sort of
separate states of being awakened alert
and not being awakened alert I mean
there are some creatures that have
multiple parts of their brain I think I
think called Legends for sharks and so
on I think have one of these half the
brain is asleep while the other half is
awake type type deal
um and uh we humans have our left and
right sides of our brains do somewhat
different things uh so that wouldn't
work so well to to be alternating
between sides when sleeping wakefulness
I guess
um
I mean unless you unless you said I have
my nighttime activity and I have my
daytime activity and I'm really kind of
a little bit of a different person
during the night when I'm kind of
sleeping on the left side of my brain
and clearly the day when I'm sleeping on
the right side of my brain I'm different
but that's not that's not how we don't
know how not how our species are set up
but any case the uh given that biology
is sort of piled on functionality onto
sleep perhaps its primary function was
just sort of cleaning out waste products
of neural firings but then it got other
functions as well another function of
sleep is probably something to do with
memory consolidation probably the case
that to really fix something in
long-term memory one has to kind of
replay it somehow during sleep and
possibly even just the maintenance of
memories that were around from I don't
know 30 50 years ago whatever in your
brain you probably remember remembering
them so to speak rather than having sort
of a primary memory going back that
amount of time and it could very well be
that some of that memory kind of gets
replayed for one and
re-re-solidified in sleep possibly in
dream sleep and so on
I think the uh uh you know if you look
at the sort of evolutionary explanations
of sleep one of the ones which I must
say I've always found deeply uh
suspicious is the theory a lot of
animals sleep just to keep them out of
trouble during the night
um and that that's been a quite uh
popular Theory among evolutionary
biologists you know my guess is if there
is any such effect it is a piling on of
yet another reason why it's a good idea
to sleep that um uh sort of biology has
done so now the question is can one
you know is there a way in which one
could avoid the need to sleep you know I
know people do all kinds of biohacking
type experiments and certainly uh even
in the distant past people had who had
very regular schedules I know this was
true of some uh some Monk scientists who
would go and say well I'm gonna sleep
one minute less every day for the over
the course of you know a decade and then
I'll be down to only needing three hours
of sleep per night
um I think
um it's uh you know it's it's unclear
whether whether we work biologically
successfully on that and certainly
there's I think decent evidence that all
sorts of bad things that can happen to
older brains are more likely to happen
if you haven't had enough sleep
um so the sleep is probably of uh uh a
value to maintaining sort of the the
health of the brain and and certainly
one knows if if you actually Force
forcibly don't sleep for long enough you
eventually die so that's kind of a sign
that sleep is necessary uh to for for
things to keep working
but any case the thing that um uh uh is
you know cam one sort of reduce the
amount of sleep one needs uh I have to
say I personally have never tried to do
that I find that I'm only able to sort
of have a brain that's operating
decently if I have a pretty normal
amount of sleep every day
um you know one can ask the question
between the different phases of sleep
you know rapid eye movement sleep deep
sleep light sleep Etc et cetera et
cetera
um whether perhaps some of those are
more essential than others and um people
argue a bit about how what that story is
and maybe there are parts of the Sleep
Cycle that one could do away with and
sort of save those hours of sleep time
but then there's the possibility oh
maybe there's a drug often thought to be
the solution to lots of things and and
uh sometimes is but often isn't you know
maybe there's a drug you can just you
know pop a pill and it will do the kind
of uh cleaning out of uh you know in 10
minutes It'll sort of clean your brain
out and do some kind of brain cleansing
thing and then uh uh you'll be good to
go and can keep kind of um operating
um
without sleeping I'm I'm dubious that
that will work partly because I suspect
that biology even if there was one
primary function for Sleep which you
could get in some other way that biology
has piled on enough other functions for
sleep that there'll be things one loses
by doing that
so I think in um
uh
the question of um
whether there are sort of um
um
things that you know if one had a direct
neural connection to one's brain could
would that affect how sleeping works you
know I have to say when I was about 10
years old I had this uh I had read
something in some future science book of
some kind that there was this great idea
of learning things while you were asleep
well in those days it was not there
weren't computers that were accessible
or or um uh other kinds of things like
that so the only way you could like
um you know try to learn something when
you're asleep was hook up a tape
recorder and a whole sort of alarm clock
type thing and to switch the tape
recorder on et cetera et cetera et
cetera so I did try this
um just as a on the theory of
experiments and um uh you know recorded
some uh random stuff that I wanted to
remember probably some school related
kinds of things the problem was with
this experiment the experiment I would
say was a was a total failure
um uh well I wouldn't know where the
experiment was a failure or not because
I don't remember what might have been
kind of uh you know what I might have
been exposed to in sleep but I have a
good enough memory but just the very Act
of recording a bunch of things that were
intended to be sort of sleep played was
probably enough for me to remember of
them thereby completely sort of blowing
up this experiment but you know people
do that there is the question you know
if you have a brain and uh it's sort of
more or less operating and and you kind
of want to get mileage from the brain
can you could you like connect something
to the brain when it was asleep and uh
still get mileage from it I mean it kind
of like I feel like um uh you know when
you say I can do that with my eyes
closed or I can do that when I'm asleep
so to speak uh you know maybe one gets
to actually test that I'm skeptical of
whether how well that would work but
it's certainly an interesting thing to
imagine you know could you start um
you've got this brain that's asleep and
you're
um but it's still got its whole neural
net there and you can kind of poke at it
and you can kind of uh use the time when
you're asleep to kind of be constructing
I don't know a digital twin of your
brain and reading out different things
and uh not sort of having to be exposed
opposed to that going on I don't know
just a just an idea but I don't I don't
immediately have a have a thought about
that and I am I'm very skeptical about
the uh uh take this pill and you won't
have to sleep type thing I am pretty
sure that was in the the books that I
was reading when I was a kid about
visions of the future
um and it certainly hasn't happened yet
and I'm I'm skeptical that it will
um
gosh lots of interesting questions here
uh it's a question from Tinker Holly
here as far as human evolution goes do
you believe the human race is still
evolving or have we peaked as a species
what's next in the stage of human
evolution
you know
one of the things about us humans is
that a lot of what changes for us is
things like technology
and in a sense that's a layer of
evolution beyond the biological so to
speak
in many species if you want to have
something that is kind of passed down
across the generations the only way to
do that is genetically so to speak if
you want this particular type of fish to
be really good at being able to you know
find food inside crevices and rocks or
something that that skill is presumably
something that has to be transmitted
genetically from one generation to the
next
whereas as you go to sort of higher
organisms and things there is an
increasing sense in which you can learn
something in the course of life you can
you can be kind of a blank slate at the
beginning and then in the first some
amount of life you learn this or that
thing I mean some aspects of our brains
we know work that way for example Vision
uh it's pretty certain that our sort of
neural net that does visual perception
really doesn't know how to see anything
when we're born but as we start exposing
it to the actual world with the actual
objects that exist in the world so we
start to wire up our visual cortex to
have the feature recognizers and so on
but we need to recognize the things that
we see today actually a very interesting
question is whether
given that people grow up in a in an
environment that is different in terms
of its visual appearance from the
environment that existed earlier in
human history does that affect the very
way we see my guess is the answer is yes
there's a famous experiment done in the
1960s or 70s with uh cats who were
reared in an environment with only
vertical stripes
and uh you know the cat just is it's a
stripy environment and they have some
kind of color to prevent them sort of
seeing things at an angle et cetera Etc
et cetera it's kind of a weird
experiment but the results of that
experiment is those cats didn't learn to
see horizontal stripes when they when
they you know were exposed only to
vertical stripes you show them something
moving horizontally they're like I don't
notice that
so it's an interesting point which I'd
never thought of before that modern
humans raised in cities and things like
this the visual scenes that they will
get will be somewhat different from the
ones that people have ever had out in
the wild in the past and how does that
affect their their uh what they learn to
be able to see you know it's reminiscent
of where one has image generation
systems AI uh generative AI image
generation systems were the whatever it
is you know the the latent diffusion
models or these other kinds of things
where where one is going from a textual
prompt to you know a picture of a cat
with a hat or something
um those work by basically having seen
lots and lots of images of the world and
finding sort of the statistics of how
those images work and then saying okay
I'm going to make an image that follows
the statistics of images in the world
but I'm always going to make it with
with the condition that it's ultimately
going to be described by an image
captioner or something as being a cat
with a hat and but I'm going to sort of
uh there are many many there's a sort of
almost infinite number of possible
images that can be made that respect the
statistics of natural images and in that
case you'll be sort of guided to make an
image that follows the caption that you
want but that means that those image
generation systems they have learned
from the actual images that people have
taken you know have put on the web and
so on those actual images certainly
contain lots of technological artifacts
and it's sort of an interesting thing
that that the statistics of those images
depends on the fact that we live in a
technological environment so to speak
and so it's an interesting thing that
one can imagine that even at the level
of the actual sort of wiring in our
brains at a pretty low level below the
conscious level we can be affected by
the environment that we haven't defined
but in a much higher level the big
innovation of our species is language
and that's allowed sort of increasingly
abstract Concepts to be passed down from
generation to generation the primary
form of evolution that we have is
knowledge Evolution intellectual
Evolution Evolution that is about ideas
rather than about the details of you
know how how are our thumbs jointed or
whatever else
now you know talking about biological
style Evolution uh well it's always a
story of natural selection it's well
almost always a story of natural
selection I mean one of the things
that's been an achievement of recent
times is that lots of uh people born
with various kinds of uh
issues who in the past would have died
and would never have been able to pass
down their genetic material are now as a
result of modern medicine able to you
know live long and prosper so to speak
and have children
so that uh that means that certain
traits which might have been kind of
ground out of the of the population have
not been now of course there are other
funky things that happen because you
know there's there's the question of in
the in natural selection the sort of
winner of the natural selection Stakes
are the folks who have the most children
and in modern times it's a funny set of
of uh different sort of cultural groups
that end up being the large children
groups and uh there's certainly ones
where that might be you know you might
say they're a wonderful group but
unfortunately they're not having any
children and so in the biological
evolution Stakes they're just going to
lose and obviously the in the current
state of the world there are lots of
countries where the there's rapid growth
of population and where you know the per
capita GDP and things like that is is
quite low and uh then they're parts of
the world where the GDP per capita is
really high and the uh uh you know
population growth is zero or negative
so in that sense there is human
evolution and it's kind of funky because
it depends on these kind of cultural
factors that determine how many children
people have
now in terms of of
uh you know I think there's a
you know I don't know what that selects
for that's a that's a funky thing and um
uh that's that is the primary form of
natural selection style selection that
we currently have
um I think in terms of well what else
could happen I mean there are much
Wilder things that could happen for
example with Gene editing it's perfectly
possible to put new and different genes
into the kind of germline into the into
the actual uh uh you know into what is
passed down to Future Generations I
think people generally think that's a
really bad idea but uh bad ideas don't
necessarily not get done and you know I
think that's the other thing one can
imagine is something where we have a
more than artificial selection I mean so
in normally in animal breeding and
things like that one has a form of
artificial selection where one's
deciding you know that's a really good
looking cat will breed that cat and get
lots of uh kittens from that cat and not
from this cat that looks looks kind of
ugly over here
um that uh you know for the um the
concept of a sort of external Force
doing that for the human population is
viewed as a really bad idea I mean it
was popular 100 years ago with sort of
theories of eugenics and so on but
people I think have universally thought
that's a bad idea
um but it's so then the question is
um you know that that force of human
evolution is not happening it could
happen but it's been thought to be a bad
idea just as one could imagine something
even more direct than artificial
selection which is literally doing Gene
editing
um is something that could in principle
happen
um but probably people think it's a bad
idea so I think it's hard to predict
what any of those things would lead to
very rapid biological level Evolution
but I think otherwise most of the
evolution is at the level of ideas and
at the level of so that the technology
World which in a sense is co-evolving
with us humans I mean as technology you
know the the whole sort of lineage of
technology I mean it's like one doesn't
get a microprocessor from nothing a
microprocessor is the result of a big
tower of evolution of technological
Evolution just as we humans are the
result of a big tower of biological
evolution going back a few billion years
so uh the the
a few thoughts about um uh about sort of
the future of us as a species I mean I I
would say that that
the kind of
the question of to what extent
we evolve our ideas and our technology
versus to what extent we evolve our
biology my guess is that in terms of the
Natural Evolution of our biology
it's at best confused right now and not
something where we can realistically
expect
uh I mean
you know partly because through
technology we are shielding ourselves
from lots of kinds of issues I mean we
might imagine that oh gosh you're living
in a hot climate you know you'd get um
you know you'd somehow uh end up
evolving you know built in air
conditioning or something but then it
turns out that in many parts of the
world at least some parts of the world
you know you live in a hot climate and
you have air conditioning so you know
external technologically provided air
conditioning so to speak and uh uh it's
also the case that as the mortality
curves for people get to be much more I
mean it used to be the case that the
life expectancy was was quite low and
was comparatively low compared to
childbearing ages and that meant that
there was sort of much more sensitivity
to things that might kill you and the
effect of things that might kill you on
whether you have children whereas if
life expectancy mostly is extended far
past childbearing age it's like that
means that sort of anybody gets the
chance to have children so to speak and
there doesn't tend to be this
sensitivity the things that might sort
of bump you off before you get to
childbearing age
let's see oh boy so many questions
um
made of us will we ever have technology
that allow us to learn why we sleep I
don't think we know
good question I don't think we know
I don't think we know whether
uh
what the role of sleep in terms of
memory consolidation is I don't think we
know whether our sensory inputs are
active in sleep that one would have
thought somebody must know by looking at
fmri Imaging of people while asleep but
I don't know that and certainly sort of
uh you know anecdotally one doesn't have
the impression that sort of sensory
stuff is open while asleep one doesn't I
don't think people often report that
they
you know if they were in an environment
with this bunch of noise going on I
don't think that impinges on their
dreams for example I don't think that's
a common thing I think one you know
dreams are affected by the by the way in
which one wakes up and that's mostly
sort of compressing the time and the
dream into into the time while I was in
that those moments of waking up
um I'm always very bad at the things
about dreams because I essentially one
of these people who remembers very few
uh dreams they have when they're asleep
so I'm not not an expert
um about that
let's see
ah spare parts asked we're coming back
to an earlier question noise seems to be
almost inevitable when it comes to
Flying is there a way to solve that you
know I don't think noise is inevitable
to Flying I think that noise is
primarily produced by turbulence and
which is produced by kind of Rapid uh
motion that certainly are you know
planes that people built with propellers
that are these very kind of nice wooden
propellers big propellers and so on that
have produced much less sound when they
fly they're much less I think the
primary source of the sound is turbulent
flow and I I turbulent flow is not a
necessary feature of flight
um certainly not um well little insects
don't have it but um uh I think that
that's something one can avoid so I I
think and one of the things that
certainly happened over the course of
the last 100 30 years is jet engines
have gotten quieter uh through all kinds
of technological innovations but
particularly in the way that the fluid
flow works through them so my guess is
that that flight doesn't have to be loud
um and uh exactly what it takes to make
it not be loud I'm not sure obviously a
balloon is well you would think a
balloon was silent except a hot air
balloon has this great big burner in it
that's making very loud growling sounds
so to speak but in principle a balloon
is not um uh is not making sound and
obviously gliders well again don't uh
don't make sound like that but I don't
think it's the case I'm I'm sure that
there will come a time when there's when
there are quiet drones and so on how big
they have to be and what all of those
physical constraints are I'm not sure
uh
news comments there's a Japanese hover
bike
a half a million dollars interesting
uh
let's see
okay the comment here from Jamie about
how do you optimize the sky for regular
air travel to accommodate flying cars
you know one of the things
about sort of the evolution of cars and
Roads and all that kind of thing is
how smart are the cars going to get
because you know if cars were smart
enough
they don't even have to all be
definitively driving on the right or
left they could be using the whole
roadway and just they know oh there's a
car coming in the opposite direction I
have to move this amount Etc et cetera
et cetera that's perfectly imaginable
with sort of smart enough cars you know
I think the issue with with cars and um
uh this is sort of a a thing about uh
someone asked before about sort of the
evolution of of cars and such like
um
one of the
questions I suppose is
to what extent do you have individual
sort of
self-driving cars to what extent you
have whole fleets of cars that are
communicating and then what does it even
look like when cars are kind of
negotiating with each other for oh this
car you know if you go this way I'll not
cut you off at this intersection Etc et
cetera et cetera and you get this very
elaborate negotiation between cars it's
all happening outside of human awareness
probably
um and that whether where the human user
has said I want to get from here to
there as quickly as possible I need to
get there by this particular time and
then the cars can kind of negotiate well
you know we can open up this thing here
and not put so many cars through this
road which will cause it to slow down
Etc et cetera et cetera I think the um
uh another big feature of cars and sort
of communication between them is traffic
jams traffic jams are a very mysterious
phenomenon I mean the you might have
thought that you know you've got a big
road and you've got a place where
everybody's slowing down you know
they're looking to the side of the road
because there's something bizarre on the
side of the road or something and every
car slows down by five miles an hour and
you might have thought well why doesn't
that just mean people you know they're
still the same flow rate of cars well it
turns out there's this instability that
develops in road traffic that propagates
backwards and even though everybody at
one point was just slowing down by five
miles an hour you go far enough back you
get stop start traffic you eventually
get to the stop start regime where
you've got traffic jams
um and this jamming phenomenon is why
does it happen ultimately it happens
because of driver delays if everybody
could instantaneously respond to the
speed of the car in front of them it
would just everybody would just slow
down a bit and there wouldn't ever be
the this kind of stop start jamming type
phenomenon
so that phenomenon
one would expect if every car was
self-driven that one could sort of
prevent that phenomenon and just have
the cars always
full of traffic will be much higher than
it is now and I think that's quite
achievable and that's sort of the
question of how that will be you know
how how that will come into existence
will it be the case that there are Lanes
special Lanes on freeways and so on for
self-driving cars that uh are connected
into the sort of global traffic brain
and uh that um uh will not have this
kind of jamming phenomenon undoubtedly
yes but then there are questions about
you know what does the transition look
like as one's got some self-driving some
non-self-driving cars what does it take
to make the self-driving cars really
work I think on freeways it's something
that is realistic even now in
complicated city streets it's something
very challenging that I don't really
think has been seems still fairly far
away from being firmly achieved
I think that um uh
it's something where so
you know this whole question of of um uh
how do you manage sort of you know right
now road traffic is uncontrolled in that
sense in the sense you know there are
traffic lights and things like this that
try to control road traffic there
another interesting story of you know
how do you time traffic lights what's
the scheme for doing that do you how
much sensitivity do you have to the
actual cars that are around and how much
is just this light changes every 30
seconds or whatever it is
um the uh uh the theory of sort of
optimal traffic light timings is still
quite imperfect
um and there's sort of a question there
are these little tricks people have like
you know one copper green entering a
freeway it's a sort of a trick for
spacing out cars or back when I was a
kid at least they invented the um this
idea of these you know boxes and
intersections where to prevent gridlock
so it's you know you're not supposed to
drive into the box unless you can get
out of the box type thing
um and there are these little sort of
tricks to try and improve road traffic
flow
um but I think there's still the
question of of what could you do
um if you
well another another trick is these
brake lights up high so you can see
through a bunch of cars to the sort of
future brake lights of cars many many
cars in front of you and so on but
there's a question for example one
question you can ask is if you put in
special seed cars could you prevent
traffic jams I think the answer is no I
think that there's no way once once all
the cars have this driver delay
phenomenon built into them there's
nothing you can really do to sort of
prevent that and to make sort of a fire
break type thing that prevents the
traffic jam from occurring but as soon
as there's kind of more Global car to
car control and so on you can prevent it
I think
now the question of uh in the case of uh
of planes
you know for many planes as air traffic
control it's not a necessary feature in
a country like pretty much anywhere in
the world you know you can fly a plane
around if you unless you're in one of
these you know terminal control areas
near an airport you can fly a plane
around without necessarily talking into
an air traffic controller
um and uh it's so and it's kind of like
well just don't run into anything and
you probably won't because 3D is big and
um also you know if you're flying a
plane you're supposed to be constantly
you know scanning The Horizon to make
sure there are no planes they're about
to run into
so that's not that different from the
story of of cause and so on and I think
what uh where it's kind of every every
driver every pilot for themselves kind
of thing
um I I suspect one can go an awfully
long way and having lots of you know
flying cars before there is serious risk
of uh kind of large-scale complicated
congestion kinds of things going on and
my guess is by the time you can have
something which will keep the Drone
flying you can also have collision
avoidance systems that will prevent the
Drone from running into another one so
I'm guessing that's not going to be a
huge issue I mean it is the case right
now in air traffic control that even
though sort of the sky is
three-dimensional there tend to be these
point-to-point Airways that that you
know planes will fly from one radio
navigation Beacon to another
and they'll typically be you know if you
look at the sort of the plot of Where
the planes are in the world and you'll
typically see these streams of planes
going in these essentially
one-dimensional paths and there'll be
you know planes are um uh
you know even even an odd numbered uh uh
flight levels of thousands of feet or
whatever
um will be going East versus West and so
on and it is quite like roads in the sky
so to speak people have often uh I think
there are plans to to do this you you
waste a certain amount of fuel going
point to point because it will be better
if you could follow a nice smooth path
between two airports
um and you know there's a certain
question of you know how do you do air
traffic control when the planes are just
flying anywhere as opposed to flying on
this specific point-to-point routes but
I think that's something that has been
long plan I don't think it's implemented
yet
um to be able to do our Traffic Control
in that case which again gets more into
this used sort of smarter control
mechanisms to make better use of the
resources ultimately in the case of you
don't have to drive on the on the right
hand side of the road necessarily
um because uh because all the cars are
sort of negotiating with each other
where each one will go
um
the uh
um Aaron is asking
what about the future of tunnels
um
you know I think uh you know Elon Musk
has his boring company that's uh
proposing to make tunnels in lots of
places
um I think my impression is that
there are certain Innovations in
tunneling technology will make it a bit
easier to make tunnels I think it's
challenging to make tunnels over under
most cities which is the place of most
interest partly because nobody has any
idea what's buried there and you know
when people started burying cables in
100 and something years ago it's like
did they keep Good Records well not
really
um so you know you start digging and
you've no idea whether you're going to
run into some critical electrical cable
that was buried in in 1892 or something
like this
um and so I think that's something of a
challenge in most cities and I don't
know if you you know can you tunnel down
so you're sort of just like if you if
you fly high enough you're kind of out
of the main you know if you fly at sixty
thousand feet you're out of the main uh
uh you know airplane traffic levels
um similarly if you tunnel deep enough
you're out of the place where anybody
will have buried a cable in 1892. on the
other hand if you if you tunnel deep
enough you're probably hitting bedrock
and it's a awful lot harder to Tunnel
through bedrock than it is to Tunnel
through something something softer
um I have to say I'm I'm
I would be skeptical of um a I think
it's going to be a lot easier to have
things fly than to have things uh most
of the time be kind of sneaking through
through the ground and in some
complicated tunnel arrangement
um
but uh uh you know I think
yeah I don't think that would that that
doesn't seem promising
let's see
um
gosh lots of questions here
crucial comments about flying cars
flying is dangerous and requires more
training and skill and safety than
ground cars well it doesn't take
you know the amount of training
necessary to fly a drone is not very
large
um it's actually less training than
required to drive a car
so I think it's really a question of if
if it's an automated drone that is just
flying around and you know by default
it'll just sit there
um is is uh that's a um
that's not going to require more
training is it less safe to have
something you know flying because you
know things can go wrong and it can fall
actually in many ways flying can be
safer than driving because in driving
something can happen at any moment you
know it takes only a second for you to
have crashed and very bad things have
happened but when you're flying most of
the time you're just there's you know
you're not going to run into anything no
they're these moments when you're
landing and taking off there's the
unlikely possibility that you do you
know encounter some other traffic
somewhere but most of the time it's just
sort of just flying now you know can the
thing drop out of the sky well yes in
principle I mean one cannot you know
there are two small planes that have you
know if it's going to drop out of the
sky you know it uh it deploys a
parachute and one can imagine that that
kind of thing could be done for drones
which would make it you know pretty safe
actually safer than cars cars don't you
know the best cars managed to do is if
they actually crash they'll deploy
airbags but it's not the case that if
the car kind of goes off the road it'll
suddenly puff out some giant you know
airbag like thing around itself and just
sort of roll like a like a a ball or
something
um which uh so I I tend to think that
that's not so much of an issue
um
Dugan comments flying cars were taking
incredible amount of energy you think
it's feasible they would replace ground
transportation well it kind of depends
what the future of energy sources is I
mean somebody gets Fusion working
there's not going to be an issue with
that the um
you know even widely deployed you know
geothermal et cetera et cetera et cetera
that there are you know I don't think
it's clear what the future of kind of
energy sources might be but I agree that
that uh it you know it takes energy to
maintain things that are uh sort of
being pulled down by gravity so to speak
so yes that that that would be something
that would be needed but I doubt that
that's the first thing that kind of
limits the growth of that technology
let's see
um
okay there's a question from Jeremy here
what kind of architecture will you need
in order to build an AI that is as good
at math as llms our language do you
think this will be a fundamentally
different architecture than a neural net
if so how do humans do math and any
self-consistent way at all
so first point is I think humans are not
very good at doing math at least not
doing kind of multi-step towers of math
humans when they turn math into abstract
Concepts that can be knitted together
one concept to the next and where sort
of the thing you figured out is five
Concepts deep go from here to there that
feels a lot more like putting together
language and it's something humans are
quite good at in doing abstract math
when it's a question of a human sort of
running the math for themselves humans
are really pretty bad at that I mean the
limiting case I suppose is a human who
can run a program in their heads and
essentially none of us can do that
it's something for which neural
architectures are not particularly good
it's something for which the invention
of computers as something you know back
from Turing machines on as something
which was supposed to emulate some of
the overall operation of humans
Computing things but then ended up doing
it sort of better faster stronger and
being able to run you know a billion
operations or something that's something
that is not realistic for neural Nets to
do and the surprising thing about large
language models is that the neural Nets
that are being used there it's really
every token that has to be produced
essentially a word that has a part of a
word that has to be produced what's
happening is you're starting with the
the data which has been turned into
numbers for what the previous words that
have so far been produced by that llmr
and then you're asking what's the next
word going to be you're taking all that
previous data you're just sort of
Rippling it through this neural net this
fixed neural net with maybe 400 layers
or something and then you're seeing at
the end what results does it get and
that's what determines the probabilities
for the what the next word will be so
it's this very you know just you start
at the beginning you flow through you
get the next word the only form of kind
of uh sort of more sophisticated looping
is the outer loop that just says okay
you're going to put a new another word
down okay go send go take everything
that that has been written so far feed
it into the large language model use
that to generate the next token and keep
going and it does that a typical large
language model does that until it gets
to a stop token and this when it
generates a stop token the outer loop
the controlling system says okay we
should stop now that's the end of the
essay or actually slightly more
sophisticatedly we should stop running
the llm now we're going to get a place
where the llm is going to call an
external tool and a bunch of the data
that the llm wrote out was actually data
that it wrote for feeding to an external
tool like Wolfram language for example
feeding it to that external tool then
there's actual computation that happens
you get the results you feed it back to
the llm as language and the llm keeps
going but so my feeling is that the the
answer to what's a good architecture for
doing sort of the the inner
computational side of math
is pretty much computers as we have them
today now there are things that you
could do that involve parallelism where
you're trying to tree out many
possibilities you're trying to find a
theorem by following many possible paths
I actually have never seen substantial
work done on uh am I right about this
yeah I think so on uh on sort of these
kinds of uh of it's even happens in
logic programming and so on this kind of
we've got a goal there are many possible
paths that will achieve that goal which
path is going to work actually that's
not true I I do remember uh when I used
to do some work for thinking machines
Corporation when they were building the
connection machine computer there was
some graph pathfinding that was
attempted on on that parallel machine
but it's not something one commonly
hears about going on it is something
where one can certainly in principle use
for example parallel computation to look
at those different paths and different
in different processes and and things
like this
um but I you know so a question would be
let's say that you are doing sort of
pathfinding in a graph you're getting
you photograph and what is the optimal
architecture for sort of finding a path
through this graph and um
actually now that I think about it that
that is something where if you have sort
of a massively parallel processor of the
kind that the connection machine
computer was
um you can imagine essentially laying
that graph out on on different processes
rather than just laying it out in the
memory of one machine you lay it out in
different processes and you're basically
looking for communication between
processors to try and find those paths
but I don't think that's a that is
something one could imagine
um having is sort of a graph processor
like that actually now to think about it
I think I know one example of a company
that's trying to do that
um but so yes I can imagine that type of
that type of thing being interesting
um I I think uh the sort of
traditional neural Nets the big
Discovery is well they're good pretty
good at language they're pretty good at
generating images they're pretty good at
a lot of tasks that we humans are pretty
good at and so in this kind of bizarre
Arc of history of neural Nets having
been invented in the 1940s to emulate
brains well it turns out eventually the
technology gets the point where yes they
can really do the kinds of things that
brains can do but it long after we got
to be able to do lots of things that
brains can't do with more traditional
computers
uh
let's see
Bob asks does AI being an interface to
books means there will be more subject
matter experts or fewer of them
interesting I think there will be more
pop-up subject matter experts by which I
mean
one didn't spend a decade learning that
field but one was at some moment one
really started caring about it and one
said with the help of one's AI so to
speak one learned that field and the AI
can help in two ways one
that's a in most Fields there's a
certain amount of mechanical kind of
structure that you need to learn and a
lot of that or you need to learn if
you're going to do it all by hand and a
lot of that is probably automatable and
you could probably pretty much tell your
AI what you want
um hopefully it will then make some kind
of computational language both language
um that uh is the thing that allows you
to kind of see did I really precisely
Define what I wanted to Define and then
you build from there so to speak
um
I think the uh uh and it will be less a
thing where you say well gosh in order
to do uh palmatopoe Theory or something
I have to learn all the stuff about how
to compute you know homotopic groups or
some such other thing well actually you
need to learn the principles of this and
you need to learn to figure out what
question to ask but a lot of the
mechanics of how you compute these
things might be is is likely to be
automated so it kind of reduces the uh
the kind of the necessary depth of sort
of mechanical learning that you have to
do to get into these fields which means
that it's much cheaper to get into the
field which means that there'll be more
people who are capable of operating
within that field
now I think
what does it mean to be a subject matter
expert sometimes there's a certain
amount of sort of mechanical stuff one
learns to do there's certain number of
facts one learns to be able to recall
but there's also a certain amount of how
do you think about things in that domain
and that's the thing which I think
ultimately is the most valuable aspect
of subject matter expertise is sort of
how do you think in that domain if
you're thinking about things as a an
economist or something there's a certain
way of thinking about how things work
you're thinking about things as an
evolutionary biologist there's a certain
form of explanation way of thinking
about things that works you're thinking
about things as a as a computational
language designer there's a certain way
of thinking about things and so on that
way of thinking about things is really
the valuable a valuable part of the
subject matter expertise and a part that
isn't the part that is sort of most
automatable so to speak but I don't know
how quickly and effectively people will
be able to absorb those sort of ways of
thinking one would imagine that kind of
with sort of AI assistance and AI as the
teaching Aid where the AI knows what you
know and can figure out what it should
tell you to get you to sort of take the
next step one imagines that those things
will get a bit faster to to be able to
do so
I think in terms of
uh so my guess is that many more people
will be able to be subject matter
experts in many more things if by
subject matter expert we mean able to
think about things and do things in that
subject area when given the appropriate
tools so to speak
uh movie my guess and I think that the
value of kind of knowing broadly lots of
different things is is going to increase
and the value of knowing the sort of
tall tower of of mechanical specifics
will decrease
let's see
uh
well Parker's asking
um
so several questions here
Pedro is asking will technology carry us
away from The Human Condition or allow
it to flourish
interesting question I mean
we can look at history for some lessons
about that
I think
that
there were times when it was just harder
to keep living you know you had to grow
your own food you had to be able to deal
with lots of kinds of things which
technology or sort of the structure of
modern society made pretty easy for a
large swath of people
and I think that um
well I would say that the the history
tends to suggest that
things getting easier for people and
people having to do less
just to survive things getting easier
for people has tended to lead to these
times of great advances in our
civilization if by advances we mean kind
of the developments of intellectual work
the developments of creative kinds of
things those are the times whether it's
the Renaissance you know in Italy
whether it's you know ancient Athens
whether it's uh even ancient Babylon
things like this whether it's uh you
know the the Heyday of the British
Empire whatever I think that the lesson
of history is when the going gets easier
for people people do more interesting
things
now I'm not sure how long that lasts I
think many of those examples from
history it was a burst of energy that
lasted for a few decades or a little bit
more and as people kind of got used to
oh we can just sort of sit back and
relax uh things perhaps didn't continue
to have that same level of vibrancy so
maybe maybe the the moment that's of
greatest interest is the moment where
sort of a lot of things that people
previously had to do were no longer were
no longer things people had to do I mean
imagine a situation in which most of the
kind of uh economically important work
that people do let's imagine that most
of those things that people uh have to
do whether it's in manufacturing or
whether it's in uh sort of
administration or whatever else or just
sort of moving papers around the world
or virtual papers around the world and
things imagine that they came in moment
when gosh we got this Ai and it can just
do all of those and in a very short time
a lot of people who were previously
having to kind of go into an office
every day and do a bunch of work they
didn't particularly like doing in order
to make a living and so on imagine if
suddenly that wasn't necessary and you
know imagine there was uh you know
whether the Dynamics end up being
Universal basic income or something
quite different imagine that suddenly a
lot of people were in this position
where uh there's sort of a lot of the
kind of the the grind of life was
removed what would happen
you know I think that's an interesting
question for modern society I think for
some people that would lead to a kind of
flourishing of things that I think we've
generally valued as a society and for
some people it would lead to I'm
completely bored and I'm going to do
crazy stuff
um or just I'm not very happy because
I'm completely bored I mean it always uh
it's always one of these things where
when people retire it's always a very
dangerous thing to do because when
people are doing stuff there's kind of a
you know a a flow of of successive days
and when people sort of retire and say
well I'm not really going to do anything
anymore that's that's usually not a uh a
very uh you know a a healthy situation
to be in unless you have something you
really really want to be doing so I mean
I think this question of if people don't
have to do anything will that be good or
bad
the lesson of History would tend to be
for at least some stardom of people and
it's a good question which I don't know
the answer to in these moments of sort
of really advancing and flourishing as a
result of prosperity
was it the case that sort of at all at
all parts of society that things were
good or is it just that a small set of
people who would otherwise have been
grinding doing something where they
couldn't do creative work for example
was suddenly freed to do creative work
and that's what gave us the main thing
that we know from that period in history
I don't know the answer that's a good
question and I think that um uh
so you know the question of whether if
we removed sort of the grind
would it be the case that one
possibility is there'd be one percent of
the population that would flourish in a
way that was not possible before and
potentially would lead to Innovations
Creations Etc people say that was a
really cool thing to have been able to
achieve
but that perhaps even 99 of the
population with the grind removed would
actually not have such a happy time of
it and then you have to ask the question
it's sort of a very political philosophy
utilitarianism type of question if that
was the case if sort of the the removal
of the grind led to a sort of dramatic
flourishing of a small part of the
population would that uh kind of um you
know what does one want to have happen
there and I'm not sure you know I think
that um
uh
when most kinds of Technology
people find
you know generally when when it's mostly
bad and there's very little good in it
it doesn't have that much of a chance to
survive as a technology but when there's
plenty of good in it but nevertheless
some bad it will tend to survive and and
the bad you know it'll be a complicated
story whether whether the bad eventually
overtakes the good but I think
um
yeah it's it's a I mean I suppose it
depends a bit what we mean by by human
flourishing I mean even uh you know you
could argue something like uh does it
how does it affect human flourishing
that it's possible to travel across the
world in a realistic firm for many
people in a realistic amount of time in
a uh sort of uh economically viable way
does that mean that uh people can kind
of uh you know maintain Human
Relationships better than before does it
does the fact that there's there's
phones or that there's video
conferencing does that increase
flourishing I think one would assume if
one looked at it from the past one would
have said absolutely that will increase
human flourishing I think now it's like
well I suppose people would people have
adapted to it people adapt very quickly
and they say you know again from the
past people say if only we were able to
have blah blah and blah it the world
will be a better place so to speak and
then such and such a thing arrives and
then people kind of get used to it and
they just say oh yeah it's just the way
the world is and um uh and then they
find the things that are wrong with it
and then they say well maybe we should
get rid of it not remembering that there
were all these things that people really
thought were good about it
so I don't have a great answer to this
question though I think it's a it's an
interesting and important question
um
the uh
Diana is asking what is the future of
libraries look like
you know I'm embarrassed to how rarely I
go into a physical Library these days
when I was younger I was a huge
Enthusiast of libraries I could find all
these amazing things that were in books
and journals and so on and uh they were
you know that was how I understood
things about the world as soon as there
was the web
that became less important
you know I think the browsability of the
web is not I mean we have browsers but
we browseability in the same sense that
I used to do of you go look at the books
that are shelved in you know QC 175 you
know 0.1 or whatever it is you know that
some particular section of uh of a
library that shelved according to the
Library of Congress classification or
geodesimal classification or whatever
you know you can live in the 530s in the
Dewey Decimal classification and so on
and you can kind of go in a library
you're going to kind of look down the
shelf of all the books that are in
classification 530 and you'll find all
kinds of things where you say oh I
didn't know about that and that's that's
interesting and so on that was fun to do
um and you know there is obviously a way
that one can imagine replicating that
virtually on the web and the fact that I
don't know of anybody having done that
is kind of a strange thing I mean it's
sort of an obvious thing to do is
recreate different density of Library
like for example if you go to the the
library that is the fairly small library
with uh
I know a hundred thousand books for
example you look in the section on
foundations of mathematics or whatever
else maybe there are three books there
if you go to the library that has uh two
million books then there'll be many more
books in that area and one can imagine
something would be a nice kind of app on
the web
um where you kind of go to different
densities of libraries so to speak
um and uh the um
um
and you can kind of browse the shelves
and browse these virtual shops I see
Harry commenting with lots of libraries
have ebook checkouts yeah I'm not sure
that's quite the same type of thing I
mean maybe it is I I've not seen such an
interface where it's kind of the
equivalent of what used to be kind of
going into that mysterious part of the
library that wasn't clear humans had
been in for a while and going and
looking at that obscure shelf there was
a certain sense of discovery that was
quite visceral in in kind of looking at
that um that shelf where you pull the
book down and there's dust flies off
from from the top of the book and you
kind of know nobody's looked at this in
years
um but uh
you know I think
what have libraries turn into I I you
know I myself don't really know I mean I
have the impression that there's a
certain sort of community character to
at least public libraries that seems
like I'm in the town that I live in
spent a lot of money building a very
beautiful new public library and I'm
embarrassed to say I don't believe I've
been inside it since the since its Grand
construction project was done which is
sort of a a strange sign but uh my
impression is that Moore is kind of a a
a a community intellectual and other
Center is a potential sort of
application for libraries and I suppose
you know as one potentially sees more
education happening outside of the
traditional universities and things like
that that's a place where that could be
a role and it was a role for for many
early libraries I mean if you go back
sufficiently far in the past the Library
of Alexandria was basically a university
where people went to learn things and
you went to the library because you
could uh then you know go look at the
Scrolls on the shelves or whatever and
um uh and learn things from them and
there were also people there that you
could learn things from and even in much
more recent times of 150 years ago there
was a certain amount of kind of Library
situated education going on and maybe
that's something that gets to come back
now
in terms of of uh you know physical
books you know I like physical books I
find I think I mentioned this before in
in one of these live streams I mean I I
am
I find the concept that you can have
sort of this lump of knowledge and you
can sort of pick it up and you see how
much there is there and you can kind of
understand at some visceral level you
know how much of it you flip through and
how much you have it I I find that a
useful user interface maybe maybe we'll
get some augmented reality version of
virtual books that's just as good as
that but uh so far at least the physical
version has been useful and even the
even the process of producing a book
where you really have to just sort of
line up all the docs get this thing
ready you're going to make a print run
it is you know it's all ready it's all a
thing that's there and there's no sort
of tentacles that you can kind of add
later I think I think that helps to
define something which is useful
um
ah okay prototype says there's a virtual
self-browsing experience called open
Library Explorer shows you cover art and
titles okay I have to check it out
um
the uh
Rob is commenting the future of
libraries the anti library with more
books being collected than read
I don't know I think I mean
you know I have about 10 000 books I
think
um and I have a one day I'm gonna do
some live stream tour of my my book
collection and library and so on I just
keep on not getting around to that
because it's a bit more technically
difficult than what I usually get to do
here
um but uh
the um uh for me
you know it is really nice to be able to
uh you know browsing it is convenient I
would say that the the pure collecting
of books
um
for the sake of collecting them becomes
sort of an investment story and not
really one that I'm so interested in but
uh I think
um
uh you know it's always a funny thing
libraries
that's that's some sort of secret
advantages to libraries like for example
libraries tend to have a nice uh
acoustic environment and part of the
reason for that is that when you have a
book on a shelf there's this air gap
above the book and sound gets into this
kind of helmholtz resonator space that
is is sort of behind the book and so
books are really good absorbers of sound
they're better than you know you can
have those fluffy things that you put on
the wall and so on and acoustic tile and
things like this books are really good
sound absorber so that's independent of
their intellectual value or whatever
they create a certain Ambience just as a
result of things like that
but I think um
yeah I'm not um
it's
well as I say I like physical books but
I have to say I'm I'm not sure uh what's
the kind of um
um
uh almost what the Strategic future of
large collections of them as I
I have a friend who
runs the internet archive who has been
scanning a large number of books and has
giant containers full of millions of
books and he's been wondering what to do
with those millions of books and whether
whether he should create kind of a book
theme park or some such other thing
um that is sort of a destination where
you can go and and browse you know three
million books or perhaps have uh it's
just unclear what you do with that
um
let's see I should wrap up soon here but
um uh
boost is commenting that they
value their personal library with
technical reference books and so on and
lots of things that can't be found
online yeah it is a funny thing what
you know I don't know what the curve is
going to look like of the point at which
sort of everything
that is at all published can be found
online I mean these efforts to scan
books
and other documents have been reasonably
successful I would say that the the real
peak of success I consider to be
documents from the 1800s documents that
are out of copyright
um I know in historical work that I've
done it's just spectacular what you can
get from particularly the 1800s of you
know all these newspapers and everything
and sort of you know when will it be the
case that anything that was broadly
printed can be found online I don't know
what the rate of sort of closing of that
process is
um there's certainly a uh and it depends
a bit on the actual mechanics of
scanning things has not really Advanced
that much in quite a few years I mean
it's it tends to be that you have you
know you take a book you put it on this
you know usually a an inverted v-shaped
uh glass thing you have camera
underneath it you you know you might
have a foot pedal where you press it and
it it flashes and takes picture sure you
go on you turn the page you put it down
again you flash it again
Etc and you know there are different
schemes for doing that but it pretty
much amounts to that and I don't know
whether there's been much advance in
automatic book page Turners I think
that's a challenging robotics problem
and when it comes to scanning just
random documents you know I have taken
some trouble to scan paper documents
that I have and I think I have now I
haven't counted actually recently but
I'm guessing it's around so probably
approaching half a million pages of
scanned documents that are uh most
things that I've ever kind of dealt with
well most non-scratch paper kinds of
things that I've I've ever sort of dealt
with mostly from the early 1980s and
well early to mid 1980s and before when
sort of everything I did was done on
paper and you know it's been I would say
that the process of scanning all that
stuff is surprisingly difficult and it
takes surprisingly much human effort and
you know you can if you're lucky
there'll be some stack of paper that is
all nicely the same size in the same way
up and all this kind of it doesn't
matter if it's the same way out but the
the same size and so on and you can just
put in an automatic feeder and it'll
just go you know Ripple through and and
uh and scan each page but I would say
that that's very much the minority
experience most of the time you really
have to go painstakingly essentially
item by item putting on a scanner
flashing it going on getting the next
one and so on it's it's a surprisingly
non-automated process to this point and
my guess is it is not one that is easy
but will easily become robotic anytime
soon
so
that uh but I you know so I wonder
whether in another 20 years whether it
will be the case that sort of anything
that's been printed in reasonable
numbers you can expect to find online or
whether it will still be the case that
there's lots of stuff where that isn't
true
um I think there will be certainly some
issues of kind of copyright issues and
so on where sort of the alignment even
when people want their things scanned
and they own the copyright getting sort
of the connection between that and the
people who are doing the scanning and
the distribution of the scans and so on
is is still a very imperfect setup at
the present time
all right well a few uh some
interesting questions and I see a lot
more that I look forward to addressing
another time I think we should wrap up
for now and thanks very much and uh see
you another time bye for now